[Music]
all right good evening and welcome to
tucker carlson tonight i'm brian
kilmeade and according to reports i am
going to be in for tucker for the whole
hour keep your fingers crossed now just
hours ago hundreds of pages of documents
from inside tony fauci's agency the
national institute of health were
published by the news outlet the
intercept they confirm they get this
tony fauci's nih funded what's known of
gain of function research there's that
term again in wuhan there's that city
again gain of function research includes
any research that makes viruses more
transmissible and more deadly according
to the documents obtained by the
intercept the nih was specifically
funding gain of function research to
spike the genes from one coronavirus
with the genetic information from other
coronaviruses in the process the
documents revealed the researchers
created a new more potent virus that
could easily infect humans what could go
wrong gary ruskin the executive director
of the group u.s right to know says the
documents are comma quote
a road map to the high-risk research
that could have led to the current
pandemic closed quote that research
includes a 2014 project funded by the
nih for bat coronaviruses research in
wuhan the project was led by virologist
named peter dazyk there's that name
again the president of the group echo
health alliance and the grant from the
nih authorized peter dazyk and echo
health alliance to conduct quote virus
infection experiments across a range of
cell cultures from different species and
humanize mice we've known about that
grant for months now but the new
internal nih documents obtained by the
intercept expose exactly what went on
during those virus infection experiments
on the mice according to richard ebro
he's a professor of chemical biology at
rutgers university quote here the
materials revealed for the first time
that one of the resulting novel
laboratory laboratory-generated
source-related coronaviruses was more
pathogenic to humanize mice than the
starting virus from which it was
constructed uh-oh in other words the nih
was sending taxpayer funds to there's
that guy again peter dazyk to make
coronaviruses more dangerous remember as
recently as december of 2019 just before
the pandemic began peter dasic was
bragging about how easy it is to
manipulate the coronavirus
chronovirus is a pretty good i mean
neurovirologist you know all this stuff
but they you can um manipulate them in
the lab pretty easily it's just spy
protein drives a lot of what happens
with the carnivorous
zoonotic risk so you can get the
sequence you can build the protein and
we work with ralph barrack at unc to do
this
insert into a backbone of another
virus right and do do some work in the
lab
after the pandemic began peter jazza
stopped bragging instead he organized a
letter to lancet a respected journal
from several virologists the letter
claimed the virus didn't originate in a
lab isn't that nice tony fauci cited
that letter on television as proof that
the virus was not man-made
if you look at
the evolution of the virus in bats
and what's out there now
is very very strongly leaning towards
this could not have been artificially or
deliberately
manipulated the way the mutations have
naturally evolved
a number of very qualified
evolutionary biologists have said that
everything about the stepwise evolution
over time
strongly indicates that it evolved in
nature and then jumped species
all right case closed that's what tony
thatcher was saying publicly but from
his private emails we know that tony was
actually very concerned about whether
gain of function research caused this
pandemic and today's document dump
reveals that everyone involved in the
research was also very worried about
that possibility now after reviewing the
internal nih documents published by the
intercept one biologist alina chan made
this assessment quote in this proposal
they actually point out that they know
how risky the work is they keep talking
about people potentially getting bitten
and they keep records of everyone who
got bitten chan said
so does echo health have those records
and if not how can they possibly rule
out a research related accident now some
of this research is dangerous according
to richard e bright and was occurring in
facilities that have the same safety
precautions as the average dentist's
office
here's what one of the facilities looks
like
it is not a conspiracy to say there were
live bats at the lab
it is a fact
and as you can see
this video shows bats in a cage at the
wuhan institute
you can also see there a researcher
feeding a bat
with a worm and in this image we can see
researchers out capturing bats and a bat
even hangs off a researcher's hat
in another image there are mouse cages
hundreds of them we know that the wuhan
institute of virology was using
humanized mice for experiments to see
which coronaviruses could infect humans
some of the most irresponsible video
you'll ever see now in 2017 tony factory
authorized another grant in wun this
time he funded quote cell entry studies
three new identities through three new
newly identified soros coronaviruses now
this summer senator rand paul you might
remember of kentucky asked tony fauci
about that grant
dr fauci knowing that it is a crime to
lie to congress do you wish to retract
your statement of may 11 where you
claimed that the nih never funded gain
of function research in wuhan senator
paul i have never lied before the
congress and i do not retract
that statement
this paper that you are referring to
was judged by qualified staff up and
down the chain
as not
being gained
a function
let me finish take an animal virus and
you increase this transability to humans
right you're saying that's not gain a
phone yeah that is correct and and
senator paul you do not know what you
are talking about quite frankly
it now appears that tony thaucy was
lying under oath according to richard
ebright quote the documents make it
clear that assertions by the nhs
director francis collins and anthony
fauci that the nih did not support gain
of function research of potential
pandemic pathogen enhancement and the
wuhan and are truthful are and are
untruthful i should say and tony factory
isn't the only one who's been caught
lying you got ian lipkin he's a
professor at columbia university he's
one of the world's top epidemiologists
he says he's heard about a major
influenza outbreak in wuan back in
december of 2019 december 15th to be
exact more than two weeks before china
disclosed the covet pandemic global
health authorities listen
i heard i guess it was december 15th
about this new outbreak that you first
heard about right that's why i heard
about this on december 15. it's a little
early right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else